and I thought maybe I could have a
Sunday and zone out in front of the
freaking TV because hey you're right my
job is extremely stressful
your character is remarkable even when
you're not being violent there's this
this violence it seems like it's going
to burst out any second
to what extent were are you responsible
for that and to what extent did David
Chase create the character a little bit
of both I mean I have a little bit of a
temper so David probably saw that and
put it into the character I'm not Tony
Soprano by any means you know it's an
exaggeration of everything but there are
seeds there which did yeah I think so
after four or five years there were Seas
one reason people you know are good at
certain characters after a long time is
because the writers see stuff and they
put it in and it makes life easier for
you you know he's not going to have me
um I don't know what sing or something
you know what I mean there's certain
things that are in my nature and he'll I
think he'll write certain things like
that but he also stretches the character
all the characters
and challenges everybody and everybody
steps up